tiffany valentine was likely born
sometime in the late 1950s in new jersey
based on this line we're from jersey
implying that both of them are tiffany
is the older of two girls born in her
family growing up she was close to her
mother who had a lot of sayings about
relationships that stuck with her over
the years such as love is supposed to
set you free if a woman spends all day
slaving over a hot stove for a man the
least he can do is the dishes you can
always smell it on girls who sell it you
can't put a price on love never let a
man block you from what really makes you
happy if you love somebody set them free
and perhaps the one that would be the
most relevant to her once as a blessing
twice as a curse well that won't explain
your sister other than these quotes
tiffany's childhood is surprisingly
mostly never mentioned leaving the cause
of her sadistic homicidal behavior up to
speculation when you put all of her
mother's quotes together and you realize
that they're all kind of salty takes
about relationships it makes me wonder
if tiffany's mother left her father and
attempted to raise the girls alone the
mrs valentineisms come up situationally
throughout the franchise but let's try
putting them in the correct order and
building tiffany's story once is a
blessing twice as a curse tiffany's
parents started off well but things
declined when her younger sister was
born because caring for a second child
was more stressful the least he can do
is the dishes tiffany's mom becomes fed
up when her father is not pulling his
weight in household shorts you can
always smell it on girls who sell it and
you can't put a price on love sounds
like as their relationship deteriorated
mr valentine turned to a prostitute
never let a man block you from what
really makes you happy and if you love
somebody set them free finally she snaps
and gets divorced from tiffany's father
my guess is that it was quite a dramatic
falling out which will help explain
almost all of tiffany's puzzling
behavior later on as far as we can tell
she's never had any platonic friends
she's hanging out alone at a nightclub
in 1984 and sipping a martini when she's
first approached by a man who calls her
red he's referring to her red hair it's
not clear if this is her natural hair
color but red is her favorite color is
there's something i can do for you
yeah maybe there is they all end up at
the hotel hackensack where tiffany and
the blonde get busy while the man
watches she demonstrates her aggressive
behavior by ripping off the woman's
necklace while she is distracted the man
yanks her off the bed and gestures a
knife in her direction instead of
cowering away she just smiles and eggs
him on do it
do it
now
her aggressiveness with the woman and
masochism with the man is enough to make
me think that tiffany had already
discovered her bloodlust prior to
meeting this couple and she was probably
at that nightclub looking for prey she
was wearing a leopard pattern after all
she's identifying herself as a predator
the man locks eyes with her for a minute
and the blonde gets jealous in an
unexpected move he stabs the blonde
instead of the redhead and invites
tiffany to play in the carnage with him
she proceeds to stab the woman seven
more times as she breaks down into cries
of joy and laughter
wow
it's never happened like that before she
doesn't specify exactly what she's
talking about here but it does further
my suspicion that this isn't the first
chapter of her crime career the two
passionately make love beside the mess
they just created she introduces herself
and when she learns his name charles
she's the one who suggested he go by
chucky he gives her a suggestion as well
to go blonde these suggestions each
become iconic elements of their
respective characters and so began one
of the worst most toxic romances i've
ever [ __ ] seen to learn how tiffany's
childhood shaped her into a monster the
secrets behind her survival the
disturbing truth about her motherhood
and how her career as a professional
poker player helped her carry out an
evil plot in the future stick around to
the end of this video
welcome to horror history there are not
many characters who have the power to
revitalize a franchise so many years in
after child's play 3 in 1991 producers
don mancini and david kirschner were
inspired to create a fresh take for
chucky after seeing the way that scream
reinvigorated the horror genre with
satire something they talked about on
the movie's official website back in the
days when movie websites didn't suck the
fourth chucky film became more of a
romantic comedy by introducing a love
interest for the supernaturally
possessed doll enter tiffany valentine
or she would become known tiffany ray
tiffany is a name of greek origin
meaning manifestation of god she would
be the second character ever to be aided
by the power of the voodoo god at
dumbella valentine refers to the holiday
of love and romance valentine's day
tiffany's entire character has been
influenced by her mom's distorted
teachings about love although the
fanbase is split on the comedic approach
to chucky which i refer to as the
brideseed arc most would agree that
tiffany has become a fan favorite
character who stuck around even after
the movie swung back to a horror first
approach from an emotional standpoint
there's a lot going on with this
character so let's take it back to her
mid-20s to understand how she got so
messed up
[Music]
tiffany is referred to as a body
disposal expert it's clear that she has
no sense of morality but her skill when
it comes to cleaning up after herself at
least keeps her from facing any murder
charges in her 20s that being said her
disregard for other laws still got her
in trouble often landing her at the jail
time and a mugshot in the newspaper
i always dreamed of having a big church
wedding with bridesmaids and a cake and
my picture in the paper not just the
usual mug shot but something really
flattering at some point authorities
distinguished her from being a common
criminal and determined that mental
illness was a factor is mommy ill
the courts thought so she's somehow able
to stay out of an institution i would
conclude that her life of crime linked
to mental illness was a direct result of
her upbringing her mother's philosophies
make it clear that there was a lot of
friction between tiffany's parents this
medically reviewed article by clinical
social worker amy marin describes the
mental effects that fighting parents can
have on a child a lot of these describe
tiffany's behavior but for now let's
just look at behavior problems parental
conflict has been linked to increased
aggression delinquency and conduct
problems in children as these kids
develop into adults behavior problems in
school become run-ins with the law
inability to fit in with society and
mugshots in the paper shortly after she
hooked up with chucky chucky actually
kills tiffany's mother the woman that
tiff is constantly quoting yet she stays
with chucky after this and even wants to
spend more time with them i always
wanted us to spend more time together
maybe
do some traveling and see the world this
suggests that in her adulthood she
didn't have a good relationship with her
mother which could likely be a lingering
effect of parental fighting it can
affect the parent-child relationship the
quality of the relationship may be
affected as it may be difficult for
parents to show warmth and affection
when they're angry and upset with the
other parents i can basically go on and
on about how parental quarrels may have
impacted her for example it can cause
insecurity tiffany gets a tattoo on her
chest a heart with a dagger and her
boyfriend's name this study in the
national library of medicine found that
young women with tattoos reported
significantly lower self-esteem i'm not
saying all tattoo's bad i have a tattoo
but the difference is mine is perfect
and i had a long time to think about it
tiffany's is a tacky emotional crutch
that she got to impress a man that
doesn't actually care about her tiffany
also becomes a big fan of martha stewart
the article states that women who watch
martha stewart have significantly i'm
kidding after a few years of dating and
committing crimes together in hackensack
it was time for these two fish to move
to a bigger pond or should i say lake
but first there was one order of
business to take care of
[Applause]
before leaving new jersey chucky and
tiffany need a vehicle and the two look
at this 1960 pontiac parisian tiffany
loves the color coronado red because
it's her favorite color and it can
easily hide spatters of blood when the
seller discloses that the previous
owners were decapitated in the car she
gets a huge smile she gleefully slashes
the seller's throat with her nail file
and climbs into the driver's seat she
also takes a little taste of his blood
along with weaponizing her nail file
this is something that becomes a
signature of hers as they set off she
notices chucky reading something about
voodoo something that would become a
very big part of her life later on they
arrive in chicago illinois in 1988 and
get their first apartment together she's
immediately blown away by it and begins
interior designing in her head and
martha stewart has been rubbing off on
her charles suggests they order her
pizza and she loves the idea because she
knows exactly what that means not only
are they ordering a pizza but they're
also ordering a pizza delivery man and
new victims are just as satiating as
deep dish for these two they share a
cigarette afterwards as they debate the
merits of chicago versus jersey style
pizza the scene also contains more
potential evidence that disaccord from
her youth is still affecting her another
telltale sign is substance abuse
something that becomes much more likely
in a high conflict family but at least
at this point the young couple is
getting along like substance abuse
violence seems to be something that can
numb over any relationship issues i
think a lot of people have had that ex
that just isn't really compatible with
you but when you're in bed everything is
good for these two it's hopping people
and like that x there's a limited amount
of times you can turn to this
distraction before the relationship
issues are impossible to ignore as they
stop hunting together as frequently
tension rises in the relationship at the
time of the original movie chucky has
his own place so my theory is that they
broke up causing him to move out but
they got back together and chucky just
kept his other apartments to use for
other purposes besides he's definitely
not getting his deposit back seeing is
what he's done with the players chucky
starts seeing another woman at this
point however it's not clear if tiffany
knew about this i don't think she did
but i'll get back to that later on
november 8th 1988 tiffany comes home
from the grocery store with ingredients
to make chucky's favorite food swedish
meatballs and catches him in the other
room finishing some lady with a knife
that's not an innuendo i mean literally
but to her stabbing solo is just as bad
as cheating she's jealous that he's
getting his fix without her a new form
of jgs that we've never explored before
she confronts him on their lack of
murder dates as of late and he just
blows off the argument it's obvious that
this isn't the first time they've
separated without being able to talk out
the problem it's a symptom of one of the
biggest effects of parental infighting
relationship issues it's pretty obvious
how this goes as a kid your brain is
still developing and adapting to your
environment when kids see their parents
fighting all the time they learn that
that's how you solve disputes and they
end up using the same tactics in their
own personal relationships which means
toxic relationships instead of trying to
fix the issue she tries to get back at
her boyfriend she calls the police
station and asks for detective mike
norris the lead detective on the
lakeshore strangler case and fills him
in on charles whereabouts this leads to
the police finding where he's kidnapped
his mistress chasing him through chicago
and ultimately killing him inside of a
toy store after his death tiffany finds
a ring on the mantle and believes that
chucky had been planning to propose to
her tiffany does know that charles had
been experimenting with voodoo and keeps
hope alive that he might have been able
to transfer his soul out of his body
before dying so she continues to wear
the ring every day she searched for 10
years there are rumors and urban legends
of a possessed good guy doll that first
appeared right after charles death in
1988 then again in 1990 but the alleged
activity always dissipates before
tiffany can get there she's forced to
move to a mobile home in lockport new
york i'm guessing she moved there in
1998 or 1999 because at the time of
bride of chucky in spring 1999 it sounds
like she hasn't been there for very long
so you're moving out already she keeps
the ring in the car but nothing else her
belief in chucky's return is so strong
that she fantasizes about having a baby
with them when he comes back and builds
a slide-out playpen in her trailer the
place is decorated all over with baby
dolls it's possible that she just has an
obsession with dolls because of the
legends about her boyfriend becoming a
doll but based on her past i have a
different theory i talked about the
emotional damage she received from her
parents fighting with each other but
perhaps the stressful home environment
also led to one of the parents abusing
her these victims tend to have their
emotional development stunted in other
words the trauma may freeze their brains
developments making them unable to grow
up in certain ways this could explain
the baby dolls the little girl voice
associated with many of these types of
victims
[Music]
childlike tantrums and many other
symptoms some of which overlap with the
psychological damage caused by fighting
between parents i'm not gonna dwell on
this too much because there's no
evidence that she was abused it's
possible that she just likes dolls but i
wouldn't be surprised if we end up
learning that her parents were a little
heavy-handed with her it seems like
she's about to move on from chucky by
1999. she starts dating a cringy goth
dude named damian but doesn't put out
for him because in her words i'll kill
anybody but i'll only sleep with someone
i love and she doesn't love him because
he's not a real killer like chucky in
1999 she hears about another potential
chucky appearance at a military academy
in missouri the remains of the good guy
doll end up in an evidence locker nearby
so she bribes a cop named robert bailey
to retrieve them for her only to slit
his throat with her nail file and
collect the spoils she goes home to sew
the doll back together and attempts to
bring it back to life with the help of
her voodoo for dummies book it doesn't
appear to work at first however damien
comes over and she soon notices that the
doll has moved she gets the idea to
chain damien to the bed and striptease
for both him and the doll anybody even
looked at me
chucky would take care of him
this is her cue chucky turns his head to
lock eyes with damian and tiffany looks
on as her ex rips out her new
boyfriend's piercing and smothers him
with a pillow bringing someone to an
early grave is what started tiffany in
chucky's relationship and it also
provides a spark for them to rekindle
that relationship here the couple are
glad to see each other for a couple of
minutes before they go back to being
toxic
it's part of a long cycle which we see
more examples of it doesn't take long
for the friction between them to start
up again when chucky makes an
off-putting comment i always thought you
were gonna let yourself go nonetheless
she prepares him his favorite meal
swedish meatballs and explains how she
never stopped wearing his ring she is
dismayed to find out that charles had
stolen the ring in order to sell it not
to propose to her when he hysterically
laughs in her face she realizes that he
hasn't changed and probably never will
she locks him in her makeshift playpen
and tells him she prefers him in this
baby-like form i think what she really
likes is having control over him since
his independent behavior is what caused
issues for them in the past the bedroom
is one thing but hopefully i don't have
to explain why it's not a good idea to
get involved with a woman who is a
control freak in all aspects of life
this is another aspect of her character
that stays with her through the years
that night she removes her ring for the
first time and weeps in her bed next to
damien's lifeless body the next day she
would look for love elsewhere but her
search and her life would be cut short
[Music]
the next day tiffany gets her neighbor
jesse miller to help her load the trunk
containing damien's body into the car
she asked jesse out on a date that
evening but jesse has a girlfriend so
tiffany tells him to treat her right and
heads off to dump damien in the east
river which according to buffalo native
and fellow youtube creator bryce edward
brown is the prime location to dump
bodies in new york i'm not sure why he
knows that on the way back she buys a
female doll about chucky's size and puts
it into the playpen with him to be his
new partner to taunt him that evening
she takes a bath and giggles as she
watches the news report on her most
recent string of victims before
switching to bride of frankenstein which
she seems moved by perhaps because of
the monster's unconditional interest in
the bride upon their meeting while
tiffany is distracted chucky escapes his
cage and pushes her tv into the bath
causing her to be electrocuted to death
this is where most people do that joke
that the video is over but i'm kind of
sick of that meme so let's just skip to
the part where chucky transfers her soul
into the female doll and she wakes up
realizes what happens and is horrified
with both of them in doll form chucky
wants to marry her so she can love serve
and obey him hopefully i don't have to
explain why it's not a good idea to get
involved with someone who has those
intentions tiffany is more interested in
transferring back into a human body but
chuck explains that to do that they need
an amulet called the heart of dembele
which was buried with chucky's corpse in
hackensack new jersey they come up with
a plan to get jesse to drive them to the
cemetery for one thousand dollars under
the ruse that tiffany can't deliver the
dolls because she's taking care of a
friend who's mentally incapacitated
before leaving she gives herself a
makeover to look more like her human
self which i don't get because she's
planning to go back to a human form in
just a couple days women next there's a
scene that isn't shown in any movie but
it's kind of important to talk about
chucky and tiffany hide tiffany's
discarded human body somewhere so that
jessie doesn't come into the trailer and
discover it rotting there this works to
their advantage much later on but we'll
get to that after finding tiffany's note
jesse makes an unexpected stop to pick
up his girlfriend jade with plans to run
away and get married which tiffany finds
romantic but chucky finds sickening oh
that's so romantic i give him six months
three if she gains weight they watch as
jade's uncle the lockport police chief
warren kincaid tries to plant drugs in
jesse's van so tiffany creates a trap
using nails in an airbag designed to
kill warren when he goes to investigate
her giggling in the front seat they hide
the chief under the back seat before
jesse and jade get back they must have
been able to hoist him up there due to
the super strength afforded by dumbella
when jessie and jade come back they stay
in a barbie mode around humans to try to
get to their destination without raising
suspicion the van immediately gets
pulled over by another cop the chief's
lackey officer norton as he searches the
vehicle tiffany kicks him in the head to
prevent him from finding warren's body
but as a result he does find the drugs
that were planted there wanting to keep
their journey on track and their
chauffeur out of prison chucky borrows
tiff's lighter and she watches with
delight as he uses it to ignite officer
norton's gas tank
jesse speeds away from the scene which
tiffany refers to as chucky still
knowing how to show a girl a good time
once again all logic about the
compatibility of their relationship goes
out the window for her when she sees
chucky do what he does best the two
dolls giggle as jessie and jade bicker
about what just actually happened they
stop at a small chapel in niagara falls
to tie the knot and tiffany shares her
longtime dream of getting married which
actually causes chuckie to stop and
actually give her a real apology i guess
being back on the run from the law with
her reminded him of their younger days
and struck a chord with him every time
blood spills they seem to get a little
bit closer to add to the romance warren
who is somehow still alive pops up in
the back of the van and chucky stabs him
in the back to finish the job that night
they all stay in the honeymoon suites
motel in niagara where another couple
barges into jessie and jade's room and
tiffany notices the woman steal jesse's
wallet obviously this woman doesn't know
that dolls are alive so tiffany ends up
being the only one to see this happen
and it enrages her i'm guessing tiffany
is not suddenly taking some kind of
moral high ground and that this is more
about trying to ensure that their
journey is not interrupted again she
sneaks into their room and hurls their
champagne bottle at the mirror on the
ceiling causing it to shatter and slice
them apart on the way down the first
example of tiffany's very impressive
throwing on chucky is absolutely smitten
after seeing this
i love you he steals the ring finger of
the newly deceased newlywed and uses it
to propose to tiffany for real this time
and she's brought to tears from this
point she goes by tiffany ray after
realizing she has one human bodily
function her tears the two decide to
test another chucky believes that he
doesn't need to use a rubber because
he's all rubber despite actually being
made of plastic so the two brush it off
and continue their intimate moment this
moment would have dire consequences
tiffany becomes pregnant and because the
two dolls are being kept alive by the
power of voodoo this is a voodoo
pregnancy which means everything is
accelerated and only takes a couple of
days until delivery despite that they
don't realize that they've just
conceived a child later that night they
come up with a plan to transfer their
souls into jesse and jade's bodies once
they've reacquired the amulet the next
morning they have to make a quick exit
when the maid discovers the bodies of
the other honeymooning couple and jessie
and jade are surprised by the appearance
of their friend david who shows up to
help with the newfound relationship
issues being caused by the murderous
dolls that they're towing when david
accidentally finds warren's decomposing
remains in the back he grabs the chief's
gun and demands that they pull over just
as a passing cop recognizes jesse's van
and approaches the change in
circumstances forces chucky and tiffany
to make themselves known by pulling out
guns of their own which i have no idea
how they obtained and take the three
humans hostage this frightens david so
much that he backs himself into oncoming
traffic so tiffany gives jesse the order
too get this heap of [ __ ] moving after
getting away they steal an rv from an
older couple by shooting them in the
head so that they won't be recognized on
the road tiffany ties up jade and gives
her a makeover presumably preparing for
the moment that she moves in to jade's
body she also makes some meatballs and
cookies in the oven for her new husband
but quickly becomes enraged when chucky
makes a comment about the dishes not
being cleaned jade and jessie make a
couple strategic remarks to kind of turn
tiffany and chucky against each other
jade edges tiffany to retaliate after
feeling underappreciated and this starts
a huge fight which includes dish
throwing bickering and insulting
chucky's manhood take it from me honey
plastic is no substitute for a nice hunk
of wood jade uses the distraction to
kick tiffany into the oven and the rv
crashes in the ensuing chaos
conveniently right into the cemetery
where they need to go tiffany's skin
bakes inside the oven increasing her
rage even further she busts out and
attacks jade biting her in the ear
before jesse grabs her and throws her
out the window she's unable to get to
her gun before jesse and he takes her as
a hostage to counter chucky who is
holding jade at gunpoint they come up to
the grave plot of charles lee ray where
the exhibition is currently in progress
when jesse and tiffany get there chucky
has recovered the amulets the two make
an exchange jade will go back to jessie
in exchange for chucky getting tiffany
back but something is different about
her demeter this time around she's
really had it with chuckie we see the
difference in how jessie and chucky
treat their women jade falls into
jesse's arms but chucky lets tiffany
fall to the ground this allows tiffany
to see how she wants to be treated
versus how she's actually treated in
real time and for her this is the final
straw
[Music]
jesse and jade find themselves tied up
by chucky who attempts to perform the
dembele a chance to possess their bodies
but before completing the ritual tiffany
tells chucky that she loves him and that
they belong together but while kissing
him she steals his knife and uses it to
stab him in the back before clarifying
that they do belong together they belong
together in hell the two fights and
chucky stabs her in the chest but she at
least creates enough of a distraction
for jesse to knock chuck down into the
open grave where he's ultimately killed
once more after the dust settled the
lead detective on the jessie and jade
case discovered tiffany's charred
remains and she springs to life with the
very last of her energy to give birth to
a child before she gives out in a way
fulfilling her mother's prophecy that
love would set her free it's not known
exactly how but chucky and tiffany's
doll bodies end up in the hands of a
movie studio rather than in another
evidence locker tiffany's human body is
still never discovered she remains dead
for another five years until march 18
2004. the dolls have been adapted into
animatronics which are being used to
shoot a movie called chucky ghost psycho
in which tiffany helps chucky defeat a
man pretending to be santa claus during
a break they're sitting in a prop room
when their child who has since been
given the name [ __ ] finally tracks
them down and reads the inscription
found on the back of the heart of
dumbella which brings both chucky and
tiffany to life with a jolt of
electricity tiffany's motherly instincts
immediately kick in and she asks where
his parents are before realizing who he
really is as the two embrace she calls
him sweet face the same name that she
had given to jessie when she was hitting
on him maybe this is not that big of a
deal but i do find it a little bit
off-putting that she time and time again
has shown no separation between romantic
love and motherly love we see it again
much later when she reunites with the
doll chucky aka her husband and treats
him like a little baby but we've got a
lot to cover before we can even begin to
unpack that and i'm not saying it's
weird for couples to use pet names like
a lot of people do that although it is
cringe but it's more the way that
tiffany does it in addition to her other
pre-existing derangements that makes me
feel that this is just another example
of tiffany's poorly adjusted behavior
before sweet face can finish filling
them in on where they are the
animatronic effects artist comes in to
work on tiffany but gets a shock upon
opening her up to find real human organs
chucky tosses a length of string around
a man's neck and tiffany helps do the
honors of decapitating him with it once
again this act overwhelms the two of
them with passion and all past drama is
forgotten as they share a kiss which is
interrupted by the sound of their kid
pissing his or her pants come to think
of it they never did get around to the
whole gender reveal party considering
they were both killed right as he was
born so when they go to check things out
for themselves the kid has no genitals
just as you would expect from my
children's doll tiffany wants her child
to be a girl while chucky wants a son
chucky names the kid glenn and tiffany
goes with glenda the nomenclature was
inspired by the 1953 drama film glennar
glenda i'm just gonna go with glenn for
now to make things easier the gender
disagreement would be the source of a
lot of confusion for the child later on
but before arguing any further they're
interrupted by hollywood actress
jennifer tilly who is using this room as
a secret snacking location tiffany is
starstruck upon seeing her idol perhaps
miss tilly was an inspiration to her
because she looks and sounds just like
tiffany did when she had a human body
jennifer tilly soon realizes that the
decapitated head on the ground is no
movie prop and the movie gets shut down
to let the crime scene procedures begin
the frenzy of paparazzi provides a
distraction for tiffany and her boys to
sneak out and stow themselves away in
jennifer tilly's limo tiffany is dazzled
by the sight of the hollywood sunset and
it seems to inspire her to develop a new
plan to be a part of that socal stardom
by transferring her soul into jennifer
tilly's body and for chucky to take over
the body of rapper movie producer redman
so that they can be the most powerful
couple in hollywood or something however
and that leaves glenn still needing a
body and tiffany doesn't want to get
pregnant again so she plans to knock out
jennifer before performing the soul
transfer ritual using her as what she
calls a surrogate mother and what the
rest of us call human trafficking i
think sometimes tiffany likes to
re-contextualize the horrible things
that she does to distract her from how
horrible they are like earlier on when
she refers to her killing sprees with
chucky as dates as they put their child
to sleep that evening he asks a question
that they're not prepared for why do you
kill people chucky wants his kid to grow
up to become a killer but tiffany thinks
they should set a good example now that
they're parents and she nags chucky
until he reluctantly agrees to stop
killing mostly to shut her up later that
night tiffany sends chucky into the
bathroom with a cup to start the
artificial insemination process and
later knocks out redman with mrs tilly's
most improved actress award she
confronts and scolds jennifer on her
lack of self-respect for trying to sleep
her way into a role then immediately
changes tones and asks her hero for an
autograph which of course freaks
jennifer the [ __ ] out maybe that was
part of the plan jennifer runs for it so
tiffany once again displays her
impressive cannon of an arm and nails
her in the back of the head with a
trophy the two dolls drag the
unconscious movie stars to bed once
again we see the added strength that the
magic of dumbella gives to help them
move these bodies but even still
she's fat i can't believe that she's not
even pregnant yet tiffany is the one who
um decorates the cake the next morning
is march 19th and tiffany's plan works
because jennifer wakes up thinking her
battle with the three-foot plastic
superfan was all a dream meanwhile tiff
reads up on kicking her addiction to
committing homicide she kind of skims
through the first eight steps but the
ninth tells her to make amends with
anyone she might have harmed so she
starts by calling up ruth bailey the
widow of the police officers that she
killed five years earlier her apology
confuses and distresses miss bailey but
tiffany seems oblivious which i see as
another coping mechanism to help her
ignore how harmful her actions really
are in the evening jennifer tells redman
that she's pregnant again the signs show
up much faster than usual because the
father is being kept alive by voodoo
thus making it a voodoo pregnancy
redmond informs her that he got a
vasectomy so he can't be the father and
adds that she can no longer be in his
movie because in his words she gots to
be hot tiffany overhears their
conversation through the vent and is
outraged and tempted to kill redman
herself but she resists the urge and
calls up his support hotline instead the
guy that she talks to is very unhelpful
though and almost encourages her by
saying that having a slip up is okay
because rome wasn't built in a day it's
unclear if this is a sport hotline
specifically for serial killers or just
a hotline for all types of addicts at
first i thought it was a hotline for all
types of addicts which would explain why
he doesn't make a huge deal out of her
having a slip up but again i'm not sure
what he's talking about with this line
and believe me it was not pretty
in fact it took me three hours just to
clean up the mess i guess he could be
talking about a messy maid while he was
drunk or something but it almost sounds
like it actually is a serial killer
hotline regardless his advice encourages
tiffany to invite herself to dinner with
redman that evening
glenna notices his mother cutting out
red man's intestines and tiffany is
embarrassed to have broken her vow in
front of him an event that he doesn't
really know how to process the next
morning march 20th chucky and tiffany
watch the execution of martha stewart in
bed when they hear jennifer's horrified
reaction about her now very visible
pregnancy jennifer calls her assistant
to vent about this scary new development
and tiffany joins in on the call to
confuse and torture them since her voice
is identical to jennifer's she finds
chucky tying jennifer to the bed and he
accidentally drops a photo of him and
glenn killing the paparazzi this sets
her off because of their agreement not
to kill anyone to set a good example for
their child a huge argument ensues and
it's not long before they're back on
their disagreement of if they should
raise a boy or a girl there's a lot of
irony here after all of her fuss to
create a good environment to raise a
child by shielding him or her from
violence she ends up putting him or her
in the very same environment she likely
grew up in a household with two parents
who are constantly fighting glenn states
he or she cannot decide exactly what he
or she wants to be but knows that he or
she is not a killer and tiffany says
that this makes her proud chuckie finds
red man's body hidden in the wardrobe so
she's gotta call in a new male body for
chucky to transfer into which would be
jennifer's limo driver stan
i'll be right there sync it's not really
clear to me why they couldn't just still
use redman as being alive has never been
a prerequisite for possessing a body
before how else would they have gotten
into doll bodies in the first place when
stan arrives they take him prisoner as
well and tiffany thinks they're a cute
couple as she did with jessie and jade
her mother's teachings seem to have
imparted this idealized version of love
that her toxicity prevents her from
actually achieving the vitriol between
chucky and tiffany continues to build as
they prepare for the birth of the baby
and subsequently the three soul transfer
rituals
with chucky's call upon the voodoo
powers of dumbella looming an
interruption arises in the form of
jennifer tilly's concerned personal
assistant chucky finds a hiding spot so
that he can surprise and take care of
her while tiffany steps out of the room
and grab a drink when she comes back
she's faced with a very different
situation glenn has now changed his
identity and appearance to glenda in
order to murder jen's assistant with a
makeshift flamethrower
what did i miss tiffany is taken aback
by this psychotic new behavior even if
she did get what she wanted by glenn
choosing the female identity she slaps
glenda in the face telling her to wake
up and this seems to revert her back
into being glenn essentially these are
two identities living in one body if
you've seen psycho it helped inspire
this concept which i talked more about
in the things you missed episode on seat
of chucky before they have time to
really sort this out it's time to
deliver the baby and tiffany serves as
the midwife it's a boy
yes we can tell by the blue blanket that
you somehow have however to tiffany's
surprise there's also a second twin and
this one's a girl with three human
bodies collected plus one extra it's
time to perform the voodoo ritual
tiffany interrupts to allow glenda the
opportunity to choose which twin she
wants to inhabit but realizes since they
have the amulet this choice doesn't have
to be permanent the cops show up so she
rushes chuckie along to perform the
ritual and with everyone screaming at
him he snaps and backs out of the whole
thing she's unwilling to change her
course she's seen the opportunity for
hollywood stardom and she chooses that
life over an eternity as a doll and
breaks up with chucky
it's over there's just one problem you
don't break up with the chuck he
attempts to throw a knife at her but
she's saved by stan breaking free at
just the right time or from his point of
view just the wrong time she throws the
blade back at her now ex doll but with
the police just outside and on their way
upstairs all three toys have to duck out
tiffany and glenn are able to hitch a
ride with the ambulance and sneak into
the hospital room where jennifer tilly
is being tended to they hide under the
bed and listen in on the latest
information the police have somehow
cleared her of being the killer despite
being the only witness of the effects
guy's death redman's death her limo
driver's death her assistant's death and
three other people found the dead in her
home which makes no sense but the police
aren't convinced that she's mentally
competent and might not let her see her
newborn children tiffany injects
something into her iv which causes her
to pass out and once again tries to
proceed with the soul transfer ritual
[Music]
like her initial spell to try to
reawaken chucky there's something about
how tiffany performs the ritual that
causes the effects to be delayed and
this allows chucky time to get inside
and lodge an axe into her head with her
dying word she tells glenn to be a good
girl or boy and not to make the same
mistakes that she and chucky did
especially your dad but these aren't
really her last words obviously as you
can see there's more time left in the
video the soul transfer takes effect and
she rolls over now in jennifer's body
not you jennifer tilly's body but seeing
his mother get chopped up awakens
something inside of glenn and he goes
ninja mode tiff slides in the axe and he
uses it to finish chucky once and for
well once after the deed is done she
tries to console her son who is surely
full of confusing emotions at this point
we can assume they next took the amulet
to the nursery to transfer glenn and
glenda into their human bodies it's
never clearly spelled out what exactly
happens after this but my take is that
glenn and glenda are two identities
essentially two different people living
in one body so using the heart of
dambella and the voodoo ritual tiffany
is able to send glenn into the male twin
and glenda into the female twins so that
they can live separately in separate
bodies the other possibility is that
glenn and glenda as a compound are free
to go back and forth between the two
bodies but i don't think that's as
likely based on the next thing we see
the birthday party scene this takes
place five years later on the twins
birthday so march 20th 2009. tiffany has
assumed the life of jennifer tilly so
she's holding a big party at her
hollywood hills mansion as a single
mother she's hired a new nanny named
fulvia to help look after the kids who
loves glenn but literally fears glenda
tiffany also holds on to the doll
version of herself in case she ever
needs an emergency backup body or a
blunt object to beat down a disloyal
babysitter
she once again writes this off as a
little slip so she's continuing to use
rome wasn't built in a day as an excuse
to continue her killing career it seems
she has an understanding with glenda the
murderous of the two kids to keep all
this quiet maintaining the illusion of a
perfect family for glenn which is what
he wants more than anything she likely
continued living as a hollywood movie
star and poorly parenting your kids
through the turn of the decade at some
point she went back across the country
to retrieve her car which was left
outside her old trailer in lockport new
york glenn and glenda would be eight
years old at the beginning of 2013 when
chucky next pops up we don't know if
there was an event that caused tiff to
get back together with him yet again
after the dramatic breakup nearly a
decade before all we know is that chucky
somehow shows up at the front door of
the woman he was seeing in 1988 right
before he got killed sarah pierce it's
possible that somebody helped pack and
mail chucky to sarah's doorstep but if
that is the case i don't think it was
tiffany that helped it because as i
alluded to earlier i don't think tiffany
ever knew about sarah and chucky
wouldn't want to put himself in a
situation where tiffany starts asking
questions about who this woman actually
is there's no way she would help him
once she found out chucky doesn't
necessarily need tiffany's help to
package and mail himself for example in
child's play 3 he mails himself to the
military academy despite not having
connected with her yet we can only
assume he tricks someone else into
helping him or he somehow does it
himself it's not really explained
anyways after arriving in rhode island
chuggi massacres the pierce family and
the only survivors are sarah's daughter
nika pierce and granddaughter alice
pierce there's a very public trial in
april 2013 where the chucky doll is used
as a key piece of evidence and anika is
blamed for the murders and ruled to be
insane tiffany probably heard about this
in the news and realized that chuckie
was back and started to fall for him
again because she can't resist a killer
it's an inescapable cycle for her on
april 6th or 7th the day that nika's
trial ended she pulls out an old trick
by bribing a police officer to bring her
the evidence aka the chucky doll before
grabbing him from behind and slashing
his throats the same thing she did to
robert bailey 14 years before presumably
chucky and tiffany rekindle their
relationship and tiffany agrees to help
him with his plan by mailing him to his
next destination where chucky tricks
alice into letting him perform the chant
and take over her body after doing so
tiffany goes through the adoption
process to become alice's legal guardian
using the name tiffany valentine
important note she did not sign the
adoption paperwork as the movie star
jennifer tilly did anyone ever tell you
you look exactly like jennifer tilly
yeah i get that a lot remember when i
said that chucky and tiffany hiding
tiffany's original human body would be
important later this is why tiffany is
an expert at disposing of human remains
so nobody ever finds her original corpse
this allows her to be jennifer in her
day-to-day life but also tiffany
whenever it's convenient for her if
jennifer had tried to adopt alice there
would have been a huge spotlight on her
and if something were to happen to alice
it wouldn't look good considering that
miss tilly was the sole witness of six
murders that took place in her house in
2004 but since tiffany is the one
adopting the child people aren't really
going to be paying attention this also
goes back to what i said earlier about
tiffany not distinguishing romantic love
for motherly love from the outside it's
a random woman taking in an orphaned
little girl but from her point of view
she's adopting her lover which is weird
after alice's usefulness eventually runs
its course she is allegedly killed
something that tiffany later expresses
regret for even here she can't fully
suppress her motherly instincts i'm
assuming tiffany was also the person to
mail one duplicate chucky to andy
barkley's apartment six months later on
november 8th 2013 though it didn't end
well for him
this doesn't really matter though
because by this time chucky has
discovered a new spell on
voodoofordummies.com that allows him to
split his soul into multiple different
bodies tiffany would also find uses for
the spell and chucky and tiffany's
relationship would get a whole lot more
interesting
[Music]
by the year 2017 tiffany and chucky are
somehow still on good terms or at least
they're back on good terms who knows how
many times they broke up from 2013 to
2017. chucky's new plan is to create an
entire army of chucky dolls using the
voodoofordummies.com spell it seems that
there's a limit to how many times he can
replicate his soul individually but if
he can get an innocent to kill for him
he can automatically possess a massive
number of dolls tiffany is in on this
plan she does her part by visiting the
psychiatric hospital where nika pierce
is being held in captivity on january
23rd when nika enters the room tiffany
can be seen sharpening her deadly nail
file and she's all dressed up in red her
favorite color guess goth was just a
phase in this scene she's playing the
role of alice's mother tiffany valentine
as far as the public record is concerned
this woman has never been married so she
doesn't go by tiffany ray when using
this identity from the get-go the two
don't get along and tiffany casually
drops that alice is dead which
devastates nega she fakes a few tears of
her own and says that she suspects
alice's death was due to a broken heart
essentially she wants nika to feel like
she's responsible but messing with nika
was just a bonus the real purpose of the
trip was to smuggle a new chucky doll
into the mental hospital that's not the
same no
no this is the doll that they used in
alice's therapy
to help her get over the past
she thought that maybe it would help you
too
with her mission accomplished she leaves
two days later on january 25th she gives
andy barkley a call and introduces
herself as tiffany
jennifer
even i lose track which means she has
probably been freely switching between
the two quite a lot i guess nobody
noticed that tiffany got her tattoo
removed and he says he knows who she is
and he's coming for her in chucky which
she responds to by informing him that
there are three of them at the moment
chucky tiffany and a second chucky she
invites andy to join the cult which he
refuses so she delivers a message from
chucky it's just a single word
continues to carry out his plan by
inhabiting multiple dolls inside
harrogate hospital the only other thing
tiffany does during this time is split
her own soul into another body her old
doll that she kept around after becoming
jennifer tilly it's a good insurance
policy to have a backup in case either
of them gets killed when the time comes
to get out of harrogate tiffany
essentially plays the role of getaway
driver which may have brought them
closer together because she was there
for him where his older driver eddie
caputo was not i mean he wouldn't have
been on the run in 1988 in the first
place if it wasn't for tiffany but it's
a nice gesture nonetheless
okay not really they're both [ __ ]
cancer chucky walks out after possessing
the body of nika and tiffany is just
happy to have her man back in a human
body it didn't matter that it was a
woman's body this time we saw very early
on in her history that she's a bisexual
like that first encounter they make out
next to the dead body in this case the
harrigate hospital security guard i hope
they didn't do this kind of stuff when
chucky possessed alice if you're like me
you've probably wondered at some point
during this story about how law
enforcement can be so totally
incompetent charles lee ray was a
well-known serial killer in the 80s
tiffany had many of her own run-ins with
the law during that time surely someone
saw them together surely someone noticed
that her disappearance in 1999 coincided
with the appearance of charles lee ray's
fingerprints on many new crime scenes
surely eyebrows were raised when tiffany
valentine reappeared out of nowhere to
adopt the last remaining family member
of charles lee ray's late mysteries well
it seems that at some point between 2017
and 2021 investigators finally connected
those dots and tiffany valentine is
identified as a known accomplice to
charles lee ray this information goes
public on the internet she's no longer
able to use that identity so she
continues going by jennifer tilly in
public and tiffany ray around chucky my
theory is that andy was the one to point
police to the fact that charles and
tiffany are affiliated because when she
talks to him on the phone in cult he
tells her i know who you are in march
2021 glenn and glenda turns 17 so
tiffany can go away on trips more often
and not have to worry about them as much
at some point she takes chucky back to
hackensack to revisit the early parts of
their relationship since there are
multiple chuckies now i'll refer to this
version as nikka chucky nika
occasionally takes the driver's seat
which tiffany kind of likes but pretends
not to notice for now sometimes
when we're together i
i see you looking at me
and i know it's you
it's not jackie
it's you and
i live for those moments if you thought
it was not possible for chucky and
tiffany's relationship to get any more
weird and toxic think again despite this
she continues helping chucky with his
master plan to terrorize america with an
army of chucky dolls to do this she
meets with hackensack's mayor michelle
cross to propose a benefit screening and
auction the proceeds of the screening
are supposed to fund better days
children's hospitals with the dolls
being sent to sick kids across the u.s
each one is a vintage good guy doll from
jennifer's personal collection if the
plan works as they hope each of these 72
dolls will be possessed with charles lee
ray's soul although her feelings for
chucky are mixed tiffany could never
pass up an opportunity like this to
spread mayhem and from mayor cross's
point of view it's a good pr stunt to
promote her re-election a distraction
from the fact that the death toll on her
city has been on the rise the charity
event is scheduled for mid-november on
november 8 2021 chucky and tiffany are
back in the hotel room where they first
made love this time with a new prisoner
and the old arguments to start up again
this time about jennifer's weight which
has basically been on a steady incline
the next day she cuts their guests up
into smaller pieces and tries to pack
him into a suitcase and her inability to
do so combined with chucky's
unwillingness to help causing her to
storm off yet again it's basically the
same fight about the dishes still going
on two decades later in mid-november
tiff puts her monster's inc residuals to
good use and buys charles lee rey's
childhood home in hackensack to use as a
base of operations for their
ever-expanding cult before the deal
closes she sits around with chucky in
their hotel playing poker a reference to
the real life jennifer tilly's side
career as a professional poker player
when she notices that nika has covertly
taken the driver's seat it's probably
her poker skills that allow her to
easily detect when control switches from
chucky to nika in a 2007 appearance on
the late late show with craig ferguson
she discusses how she worked with a
celebrity profiler to learn how to read
her opponent's body language so she
probably picked up on the subtle
differences in behavior between chucky
and nika nika is disabled from the waist
down but only when she has the wheel
when chucky's in control he can use
nika's legs freely to test her theory
tiffany sticks a knife into nika's leg
and as expected gets no reaction before
revealing that she knows it's nika she
plays along and tests her a bit learning
that nika drinks less beer bites her
nails and takes bigger risks at least in
poker she's able to trick nika into
revealing her true self because tiffany
has a great poker face she's not only
bluffing in the card game but also in
their conversation jennifer tilly won
her first professional poker tournament
in 2005 which works well with her
timeline in the chucky universe this is
one year after tiffany possessed her
body so we can assume it was actually
tiffany who made her great at poker
eventually tiffany reveals that she
knows it's nika and gets choked up as
she explains that she actually prefers
being with nega i live for those moments
she claims that she actually bought the
sherwood lane house to share with nika
not chucky but honestly i don't even
know if she's telling the truth about
that because she's kind of unraveling at
this point or at least unraveling more
than usual she says that she wants to
find a way to keep nico in the driver's
seat instead of that rat chucky but then
proceeds to randomly knock nika out with
a frying pan i think she's conflicted
about what she wants i know this is a
character analysis video but she's
become so unhinged from the constant
opening and closing the door on her
relationship with the chucky that it
almost doesn't make sense to try to make
sense of her character at this stage if
i had to take a stab at it though no pun
intended it seems like she wants to help
raise chucky's army because she likes
spreading terror but she's leaning
towards nika from a relationship
standpoint after picking up the keys to
her new house she ties nick up in the
chair in the living room and leaves her
with a kiss before heading out we don't
know exactly where she goes but my
assumption is that she's meeting with
mayor cross to make sure they're still
on for the benefit screening which would
serve as a positive distraction from the
recent set of murders that have plagued
the town over the last month or so which
of course were caused by chucky who is
still trying to convince an innocent
soul to kill as part of his ritual
tiffany's next move is to help chucky
move this along this time not with her
poker skills but her acting skills
chucky's new main target is middle
school student jake wheeler who
purchased another incarnation of the
doll at a yard sale in october i like to
refer to this one as cope chucky the
same chucky that alice supposedly used
to cope with the massacre of her family
in an attempt to make jake more
emotionally distraught cope chucky kills
jake's father then kills the ant that
took him in bree wheeler however jake
still refuses to kill but chucky
realizes that there may be another child
who will jake's cousin junior tiffany
plays a part in driving junior to the
brink of homicide one day not long after
buying the house tiffany shows up at
bree's wake she makes a big entrance
walks up smiling to the grieving widower
and plants a kiss on his lips although
her motive isn't clear at the moment
this is part of a larger effort to piss
off junior and turn him against his dad
by making him think that his mother
killed herself because logan was having
an affair she continues to push this
idea when she brings over a meal for the
morning family and a junior comes to the
door to receive it she tells him that
it's important to have a woman in the
house and plants the idea of herself as
the mother figure in junior's life which
fires him up because he only just lost
his mom tiffany pretends like she
slipped up and said too much before
leaving this in combination with chucky
hammering at home later cancer wasn't
enough huh
he had to cheat on her too real classics
dad finally pushed a junior to kill his
dad and completes chucky's voodoo ritual
this all ties into the part that
jennifer chile is supposed to play at
the benefit screening that evening
tiffany comes home and discovers nikita
chucky has gotten out of the chair and
finds her laying on the ground she
assumes that nika's in control unable to
get up due to her paralyzed legs but
this assumption ends up being incorrect
when she receives a powerful kick
knocking her to the ground this is
chucky and he straddles her with a knife
and threatens to kill her for the fourth
time tiffany begs that he can't kill her
because he still needs her and she's
absolutely correct think about it
well thinking is for losers
think again she's right bro
we need her it's interesting how she's
developed this animosity towards the
charles lee ray living in nica's body
but when she sees one inside of a doll
body she lights up and refers to him as
sweet phase they're the same person it's
just that she's been spending a lot more
time with the one in nica's body so
their toxic relationship has turned them
against each other [ __ ] you chucky
thank you jackie this is also the
example i brought up earlier in this
lesson chucky is a romantic partner to
her but she treats him like a baby
it's just weird man she takes cope
chuckie downstairs to where the army has
awakened she also finds jake's friend
devin who is tied up and a junior who
has joined the side of the bad guys
after chucky gives a speech to his
troops tiffany sees to it that the army
of chucky's is packed into the transport
truck and stows away the doll version of
herself to facilitate things in case the
plan gets off track she plans to meet
the driver the following day at the
theater back in the basement it's
basically a party for the bad guy she
tries to talk to cope chucky who brushes
her off as he's busy catching up with
nikitake she gets especially butthurt
when mikachuki brags about being able to
pick up women even in a woman's body
tiffany mentions that girl on girl isn't
the only thing that nikka chucky is
getting she's talking about peen this
causes tiffany to blow up on nikita
chucky and slap him which seems to knock
chucky out of the driver's seat and give
control back to nika at least she treats
me with a little respect kopechi senses
what's going on between nika and tiffany
and offers an apology for his
self-righteous attitude but it comes
with a caveat killer you know what that
does to me this leaves tiffany flustered
she argues that nika holds a part of
chucky's soul as well but he doesn't
care since there are 72 other chuckies
on the truck she reluctantly agrees in
tears who is it you're afraid of losing
tiff
me or her when tiffany doesn't act he
orders junior to do it but before he can
muster the courage tiff retaliates by
attacking the doll and cutting his head
off which she picks up and delivers
another dramatic breakup speech too
chucky threatens to kill her with one of
his many incarnations but she boasts
that he needs her too much she brings
out a suitcase which she explains to be
a present from glenda the violent one of
her two twins the luggage is filled with
bombs which she sets as a trap for andy
barkley when he inevitably arrives
tiffany jr and one of the 72 dolls that
junior stole are loaded up into the car
and don't emerge again until the next
day when the mayor introduces jennifer
tilly at the benefit screening and
auction during the announcement the
mayor's youngest daughter caroline
throws a fit because she wants a chucky
doll so tiffany gives her one extra i'm
sure one measly little sick child can
take care of himself here's sweetheart
your very own good guy dog she doesn't
seem to stay for the screening which is
odd because it's a prequel to the movie
that she was so moved by and pride of
frankenstein i'm guessing she's got
other things to do like meeting up with
the driver and briefing him on when the
plane leaves and how she's gonna kill
him if he's late with that she gets into
her car and turns around to see that
andy has hijacked the truck
not all is lost though she must have
forgotten about her backup plan or maybe
the tantrum was just part of a
performance to get andy to let his guard
down before this happens
the doll version of tiffany breaks the
window and introduces herself to andy by
holding him at gunpoint and ordering him
to drive to the airport if he knows
what's good for meanwhile the human
version of tiffany goes back to her
favorite room at the hotel hackensack
with nika who was incapacitated it's not
clear how she snuck nika's unconscious
body upstairs without drawing suspicion
but given that she's a disposal expert
it's not hard to imagine that she'd also
be good at smuggling live bodies she
also had less weight to carry because as
a preventative measure she decided to
cut off all of nika's limbs this way
chucky can't go anywhere no matter what
can't kick her and can't kill her as he
promised back at the basement and that
is the last we see of tiffany valentine
or should i say tiffany ray or should i
say jennifer tilly or should i say one
of the most deranged and toxic wives
ever to grace your screen obviously her
story is not over so if you want my
updated analysis of tiffany as new
seasons or movies are released and you
want to see my character analysis
timelines of other chucky franchise
characters make sure you subscribe to
cz's world for new horrors every week
ring the death bell and select all
notifications and i will see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
[Music]